hello guys I'm Greg I'm John we're gonna
watch the second trailer for Assassin's
Creed but before we do that we want to
give a quick shout out to our friends at
Full Sail University chances are if
you're into this channel then you're
probably big into movies as well if you
want to learn the ins and outs of how to
make movies then you're definitely gonna
want to check out Full Sail University
that's right they offer various degrees
both on campus and online that break the
process down from start to finish
basically if you want to learn the
process of how to make the film and use
that equipment bull sail is the place
give you a chance to explore all the
major roles that go into a film's
production so you can sort of get your
feet wet and figure out whether you want
to be more of a director or an editor or
a camera operator they've got an online
course dedicated a digital
cinematography while keep it up with the
most up-to-date filmmaking equipment
Full Sail grads have gone on to work on
a lot of the films that we've been
talking about lately like universals
Jurassic world Marvel's Avengers age of
Ultron and some of their notable grads
include Adam winger who's big on the
horror circuit right now Jared Baumann
also big horror film maker so boo thing
you wanna get your hands dirty and start
making movies you can check out their
programs online you can head over to
learn dot Full Sail dot e-d-u to get
started today
all right let's uh let's film this real
fast and we'll review it John and I I'm
not gonna lie we don't really know the
games that well I played it here and
there I don't know no no well sorry if
you're upset probably should wait for
after the reaction to say that that
would get a little bit of you know views
in it okay
[Music]
you're there to say to myself I
understand it's your birthday yeah the
party's just getting started
like morbid never mind
his name is Kellerman we've traced his
bloodline back 500 years to the
Assassin's Creed nice how does anyone in
the world knows or cares you no longer
exist
when is this place
this is your second chance
yeah
[Music]
your past you're about to enter the
Animus what you see here and feel are
the memories of your ancestor he's been
dead for 500 years
wait a minute welcome to the Spanish
Inquisition
[Music]
swish they change the music
[Music]
we're watching you play the Sealy Wharf
[Music]
looks like his ass is Chris intergrate
that's fine now
[Music]
they work in the dog
Oh
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
I think I need to like
ha
interesting ha is my continent so far
looks like a cool movie
it does this does I have a strong
feeling that this is probably already
getting video game fan backlash I
haven't looked into it yeah this is the
trailer drop the music kind of just
didn't fit for me in this trailer again
ever since we had that debate with BBS
like everyone is trying to make
everything seem a little bit more fun
cuz yeah I didn't think the rock song
was supposed to be here originally
either like it's well timed to it like
it still is cool sometimes it doesn't
feel like them the movie I thought
Assassin's Creed would be I guess I feel
like this could be really good yeah like
I feel like this could be really good or
it could just be a good enough trailer
for me to think that the thing that
worries me about this is is that one
line where he's on the arm he's like
wait no and then she like turns it on
immediately yeah that's a moment where
I'm like I don't know what kind of movie
you're going to be because I'll say like
when it takes place during the Spanish
Inquisition time like the way a lot of
the action shots are done and the
costume designs definitely do you like
look like cool video game omage to the
actual Assassin's Creed world well and
the games take advantage of historical
contexts and notable figures and notable
places and like you can access
information about the a during the game
like they take advantage of their
history I feel like that's something
that's ought to be here and I can't get
a sense for that either way cuz it's
just a movie and the videogame is nerd
take hours to play to finish one no no
whoa hold on huh sorry I mean you yell
at you like that job don't worry about I
will never hate you when the cameras
recording thank you
that's smart wise words my aunt told me
which one auntie pinky nice um what I
wanted to say is that after hours I say
I soaked up in that bit please do oh
it's alright um
I don't remember but I fit okay okay
I'll remember you go I got the sense
that part of the appeal of the games
like okay what time period are we're
going to go and play out most of this
story in it at least by the way this
trailer is proportion I feel like
they're gonna spend a good amount of
time in whatever future society this is
it seems like that is probably gonna be
a simple movie though with some really
expensive like action sequences in
production design but I feel like the
story itself is gonna play out simple
that's what I'm afraid of it and I feel
like this could be a great opportunity
for a really like complex kind of tale
with a lot of mind-bending stuff cuz
it's this deals with liked transporting
yourself back into an ancestors body in
mind and you're like you're them now you
take it over it you know we adds got a
crazy historical fiction but also kind
of sci-fi action in a way yeah that's I
mean so they can go crazy with it but
the unfortunate thing is it's really
gonna be like what a two-hour movie what
this makes me wonder is how crazy
they're gonna go with which one of them
are they gonna favor more of the sci-fi
action side or they get a favor
this is gonna be Lord of the Rings or
The Hobbit I feel like some video game
movies get it wrong and I feel like they
could easily do that with Assassin's
Creed as well is the games that we
really want to see get adapted have
awesome story to it I don't think the
Assassin's Creed franchise would have
spawned so many games if it was just
about the cool action there's so there's
so much cooler things in there is have a
little hunch
that they're probably gonna sacrifice a
lot of cool storytelling to fit in more
action sequences and more more of that
kind of cool stuff that's what I'm
afraid of and that's what I hope it does
not happen it was like you have a lot of
opportunity to have both Assassin's
Creed is a video game and so in that
spirit like of course you built in much
the want cool action but you know it is
historical fiction again and part of the
hook and part of what makes it great for
for movie territories the fact that you
can go to any time and you can really
explore it because that's what the games
are also about in a way you know while
being on this rollicking adventure so
they can translate that easily I'm a
little afraid they're gonna go a little
more blockbuster with it I'm afraid of
some be Prince of Persia but just a
little bit better than prison party I
mean don't get me wrong the action looks
so again sweet it's awesome at the
she looks sweet diagonally excellent
this to me is sort of like the John wick
to trailer actually it's like it's
showing me the cool stuff that I want to
see but it's also not showing me as much
of the stuff underneath it you know like
they're really yeah
is there a hokey character thing in this
movie at all you know like aside from
being excited it's Michael Fassbender
like that's the stuff I don't know it's
like I don't really know who these
people are very well because isn't he
supposed to be taking down the Templar
order yes the ancient battle between the
assassins and the Templars character
over time of becoming his ancestor
supposed to like develop these skills I
can combat them in the present day that
he lives in that would be a cool art to
be to be watching it's just I hope this
isn't too too like action movie shot
yeah yeah what I mean by that is like
especially after we do like it's a weird
comparison but like after we just saw
John wick like I showed it to John
yesterday that's one of those things
from like I hope this kind of does
something similar to that where yeah
when there's action sequences are
[ __ ] awesome they're they're great
action sequences but they don't shoot
the wrestler seems like an action scene
well they're taking annoyed in action
movies when they shoot their dramatic
scenes like you're still watching action
like no just just shoot a cool like
dramatic scene with character stop well
yeah there's something about that just
shooting a scene for what each scene
needs you know it's like John wick takes
every scene just as seriously as the
last scene it's just not all of them
wrecked whereas some of these movies
kind of feel like they want to get back
to the action scene so that yeah I go
through like okay we got to make you
care about this somehow they don't
actually have like the personality that
you that you crave that really hooks you
and this could like I feel like that
analogy is is best for this is like it
could very well go to like a Lord of the
Rings side of the spectrum or it's like
yeah they really took their time and
they really you know invested in the
mythology in the world but also there's
collection stuff that you want to see or
if they're gonna go The Hobbit where
it's like it's kind of sleek and cool
and even engaging sometimes but it's
also really shiny and it's yeah kind of
rollercoaster II and it's like I think
you could strike a cool middle ground
between those yeah cuz right now I feel
like the Assassin's Creed games have
this epicness of story that the fans
especially really do love and the
trailers are just showing us an action
movie right now
yeah a sci-fi action movie like this
gives me things to hope for but it also
gives me some things to be worried about
yeah and it's a it's a toss up I don't
know how it's
cuz Warcraft was giving people that hope
of life this could be the first like
video game adaptation where the story is
actually awesome that trailer it was I
get to me and my people still were
hoping for that looks like they released
yeah well cuz Duncan's okay right junkie
trying to do that you know and I feel
like they're gonna give us a cool fun
ride I just hope that if this film is
done well I get like if it gives us like
whatever a cliche kind of film they can
still execute it well enough to the
point where I walk out I'm like that was
still a really enjoyable film had a
great time a lot of visuals are awesome
Michael Fassbender kicks ass if I walk
out saying that I'll be content although
I'm not I'm not like a huge fan of the
videogames
I feel like though to really satisfy
fans of the videogames that this first
one just has to do well and if this one
does well then I feel like they do oh
yeah this cost money man I'm saying if
they do when the a video games are still
tricky if they do their part too then I
feel like that's when we can get more
crazy story I mean I don't even know if
this one's gonna have like a lack of
story or wealth of story I really don't
know I just hope it has enough of both
like it doesn't have the battery like oh
yeah we have a story but it's not this
story yeah you know there's a way to
blend it right and now it seems like
it's gonna be a fairly simple premise
cuz this is a game that has a lot of
potential to translate over into movie
it allows you to have two different
mediums going and it kind of to seem
natural but video game movies are also
still you know to this day super tricky
to get just right and I know Michael
Fassbender was very active in the
development of this film like work with
the writers I think he's one of their
like co-producers of the film - okay so
he's really been like the one speaking
for the movie and making sure like no we
really want to make sure we honor the
game he's an artist and I feel like this
is the director of this movie they've
got a really good team behind this they
got the guy who did the most recent
Macbeth with Michael Fassbender the
thing is they're getting better at doing
this now like Hollywood grabs good
directors and good stars you know to be
in these types of movies now like
they're taking them seriously that way
sometimes it seems like they're hired
just to babysit and I really hope that
doesn't happen here because they've got
a really strong team behind it and then
they got such awesome writers like the
writers of Exodus gods and Kings
transporter refueled
okay
Allegiant okay Tower Heist
okay accepted maybe this guy's written
some great I liked except great films
man fan favorite
what transfer refueled was the best of
the transporter films easily
Allegiant was the highest person one of
the divergent series Exodus gods and
kings really retold the Moses story and
of such a hey Niek fashion maybe this is
his shot to do something that he really
invested in that's true that's true
there's no need to be negative or
cynical about things that's why I'm
pointing out what he's feelings are good
John and his co-writer help them out
with those films too so yeah that's
probably gonna be a great film and I
can't wait for people say it about all
right guys um if you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a reject
you know fun fact
when he actually when he goes into the
Animas that was supposed to be a chair
they're like how it was in the games but
they didn't want to confuse it with fans
of the matrix as people would have been
in the audience like oh boy I've seen
this before this is wait a minute get me
my laser day she's confused
get me my laser disc we're scrubbing to
the scene John is Jerry what are the
reasons I I what are the reason reasons
- Jerry